I know I said I'd give you a tour of the
castle cabin next but our new couch
comes in a few days so I'm selfishly
waiting for that so let's go inside the
Wardrobe cabin real quick but first
check it out from this angle it looks
like an Angry Bird alrighty on to the
interior ugh I love this door Jacob did
a dope job turning this scrap piece of
wood into something cool
here it is where all my clothes live I
got a lot as you can see now I'd love to
one day fully finish this space and
truly build it out but for now this
totally works
hello
and uh there's all my shoes well some of
them and a great view of the castle
cabin from here here's the ceiling check
out this prototype color tie system that
we later used on our Castle cabin that's
it and I promise the next interior cabin
tour I do will be of that cutie right
there on the right